um did you start the new love island i
gave in
no i didn't how is it it's actually
pretty [ __ ] good is it really it
hurts for me to say
i didn't want it to be good i was so
ready to hate
um it's good man like
are the people like hold on i'm [ __ ]
this [ __ ] everything's going wrong
he shouldn't have gotten a wee truck man
um so are they are the people
interesting because here's the thing
no yeah the casting way better it is
way better because i look at i saw a
picture of them on instagram
not bro yeah and i was like these are
the most average joe looking people
bro like go back to the first season of
that [ __ ]
everyone was hot as [ __ ] that's what the
show was about but they sucked and like
with this season they struck
they man they nailed it they got people
who are just attractive enough to be
so [ __ ] vain in the funniest ways
possible
it's so good like man give me an example
what happened
oh dude give me something to happen on
the show
carrington and
first of all that name is hilarious and
yeah
he's the other guy he's a dude okay and
he he honestly um i i this isn't even
really a roast he just
he honestly looks like a fish with teeth
okay
like in a toupee like it's the craziest
you know just i've never seen someone
really who looks like him
hold on do you have a picture great
carrington
love island just love island bring it up
i didn't uh i didn't prepare a picture
of carrington
but yeah everyone on the show is is like
uh
yeah just attractive enough to be full
of [ __ ]
okay with the exception of a few people
but they're all mostly
full of it and the eagerness to be on tv
i imagine this is how it looks for
people in
the uk but you know they're not
charmed by any accent like us yeah so
i'm looking at these people like oh
some of you are [ __ ] garbage
[Laughter]
you just you just know deep down but
uh you know generally
everyone in there is is well intentioned
like even if they're
a bit vain they're not off-putting yeah
you know they like these right on the
british one or no
in this season they wouldn't with the
exception of a few but most of them
are you know they're they're
they're genuine people like they're
they're not the kind of people that are
like
i'm so hot i only [ __ ] talk to or i
only
yeah but you know whatever it man
i don't want to spoil too much but this
one i don't think is a big spoiler
one of the one of the contestants
she's a blonde girl she
on day two everyone's kind of joking
around because she
basically says like oh this guy i'm with
like he's mine
and everyone's kind of giving her [ __ ]
for that because they're like oh it's
kind of like early on and you're already
claiming him
so she walks away crying and then the
dude she's with is like
he's like groot as a hot guy like he
says like five words he's never
talking okay and she get she
gets so angry at him for not consoling
her when she was crying which was fair
but uh this is the dude that she claimed
yeah the dude that she claims connor
okay okay and
it was just kind of funny because he's
already a dude who struggles to open up
and and and later on you find out he's
only had sex three times
like with three people okay like
man he's the it's so funny like how his
brain processes [ __ ] he's like
i'm just trying to learn what her
expectations are i'm like no
man it's toxic already like get out of
there get out of there dude
you're already in a relationship don't
you see two days and she's already like
why wouldn't you just
she's like man she says some specific
line that i can't remember
but it was so funny because you could
see in his eyes
like there was something in his brain
that was like hey it is way too early to
be acting like this
but it just wasn't enough power behind
that voice for him to be like yeah now
we're out of here
he's just conforming to it already he's
like okay i'm a bad person
but forget all that dude the thing that
finally hit me last
night after how much love island i've
watched and you've watched why have we
never talked about that little vocal
sample
at the top of the credits song that
wait what wait which one it's at the top
of the credits song
right when the episode ends it's that
it's it's okay
last night i'm like what is that
hold on wait you gotta bring it up
do we have the screen chair on or no no
no but i ca i could just find it hold on
[Laughter]
what what is that oh i'm like why we
never talked about this
[ __ ] song hold on hold on
hold on wait which one is it which one
is it which one is it which one is it
[Music]
[Laughter]
like it's like it's not a word it
doesn't pertain to anything
[Music]
it sounds like lin-manuel miranda
that's what it sounds like dude
i was just crying laughing myself like
yo kristen who else gets hyped when they
hear this
yeah kristen miner kristen's there in
the living room
i was dying i'm like were they who was
in the studio and said hey man
i want you to lay something down he's
like all right go for it he's like just
give me a
[Laughter]
like how like just like that
like okay like kermit but he's coming
yeah one more time
[Music]
i was so [ __ ] obsessed with this i
tried to spell it out like what does
that sound
sound like and i came up with
yeah yeah spell it h-u-u-u-u-u-h-uh
y w y a a u h
yeah yeah
wow
i don't know why man it just it hit me
last night like
what the [ __ ] is that vocal hold on
you